mads flavor here sparking and mid [ __ ]
effect you understand me I got my little
black bag of goodies my little [ __ ]
that's all I gotta light it you know
uncle Joey does dog over here just
relaxing wait to do this [ __ ] this is a
little Shania Twain it don't impress me
much oh [ __ ]
like a document [ __ ] flavor
combination a banana I even got Gorilla
Biscuits tonight
check this out what's that say right
there
we got the Cosby special tonight you're
I'm saying we're going deep into the
murky waters I wish you were here but
you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up you
understand me like a [ __ ] doctor
that's smoked ourselves out in this
[ __ ] like doctor little I'll eat
it
at first you don't succeed try and try
again [ __ ] oh [ __ ] with a [ __ ]
there we go gonna make this a night to
remember little something with the
brothers is [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] the groom
channel 15 you always gotta have one of
the brothers which II understand me
classic fight [ __ ]
smoke signals [ __ ] look at this wait
[ __ ] around
tonight fight companion ten minutes
ready to rock the [ __ ] mic I'm stoned
to the gills I had some sushi I had some
salad low-carb tonight you know me baby
taking it to the next [ __ ] level
[ __ ] I got my two Jitsu shirt on
I can't lose I got my Diaz ticket I'm
cashing in tomorrow like a [ __ ]
doctor I gotta turn the air on and [ __ ]
it's like I'm gonna [ __ ] torture
chamber look at those smoke signals look
at that
whoa right off the [ __ ] roof they're
like I bought them
a little [ __ ] I thought it was
Smashing Pumpkins but it's not it's no
phantom [ __ ] up
and forget this [ __ ] right now would be
a good time for me on Jeopardy
I'll tell you what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna go to that fight companion we're
gonna have a good time and I'll see you
guys on the way home all right you know
I love you [ __ ] love my heart I'm
always thinking about you
especially when I'm blowing the joint of
debt
I say to myself what is my [ __ ]
family going right now they're sitting
around watching whatever the [ __ ] let me
tune in top them out I'm saying that
ashes [ __ ] on like a see Joey but hey
I'd rather be [ __ ] a sheep then be
straight and I'm to deal with this [ __ ]
look at us the trees are beautiful they
got nice music
I'm sending smoke signals and I love you
[ __ ] it's Thursday night [ __ ]
I'm leaving for Vegas nice and early and
that's it I don't know what else to
[ __ ] tell you I gotta go to dr. Jenn
tomorrow I'm gonna see my main man
[ __ ] Larry aka talking lamp
very nice people see this one talking to
my family getting together who needs a
barbecue and yelling and screaming we
just you just got a message on your
phone you and uncle Joey [ __ ] is with
you right now this will is [ __ ]
singing [ __ ] check take this [ __ ] off
the big 80s on me go [ __ ] yourself here
we go
little Megadeth time to get the chickens
out oh [ __ ]
that's it baby this is it we want me to
tell you you will be open to being a
limbo hanging out with broad jumping up
and down
who needs that I love you guys stay
black